Where we left off
in the last video,
we were just kind
of staring, amazed,
at this Earth's view of
the Milky Way galaxy,
just making sure we
understood how enormous
and how many stars
we were looking at.
And even if each of
these dots were a star,
this is a huge amount of stars.
But a lot of these dots
are thousands of stars.
So our mind was already blown.
But what we're going
to see in this video
is that in some ways, this is
kind of just the beginning.
And to some degree,
I'm going to stop
doing these particles of sand
and a football field analogy
because at some point,
the particles of sand
become so vast
that are our minds
can't even grasp
it to begin with.
But let's just start
with our Milky Way.
And we saw in the last video,
the Milky Way right here,
we're sitting here about 25,000
light years from the center.
It's roughly 100,000
light years in diameter.
And then, let's put
it in perspective
of its local neighborhood.
So let's look at
the Local Group.
And when we talk
about Local Group,
we're talking about the
local group of galaxies.
So this right here is the
Milky Way's Local Group.
That's us right
there, sitting right
over here, about
25,000 light years
from the center
of the Milky Way.
You have some of these
"small"-- and I use "small"
in quotation marks-- because
these are also vast entities,
also unimaginable entities.
But we have these
satellite galaxies around,
under the gravitational
influence, some of them,
of the Milky Way.
But the nearest
large galaxy to us
is Andromeda right over here.
And this distance
right over here.
And now, we're going
to start talking
in the millions of light years.
So this distance right here
is 2.5 million light years.
And just as a bit of reference,
if that's any reference at all,
one light year is roughly
the radius of the Oort Cloud.
Or another way to think about
it, one radius of the Oort
Cloud is about 50,000 or
60,000 astronomical units.
And that's the distance
from the Sun to the Earth.
So you could view this
as 2.5 million times
60,000 or so times the distance
from the Sun to the Earth.
So this is an unbelievably
large distance
we're talking about here.
And that's to get to the
next big galaxy over here.
But even these things are huge
things with many-- I mean,
just unfathomably many-- stars.
But Andromeda, in
particular, we said
that the Milky Way has
200 to 400 billion stars.
Andromeda, people
believe, has on the order
of 1 trillion stars.
So these just start
to become numbers.
It's hard to grasp.
But we're not
going to stop here.
So in this, over here, this
whole diagram right here,
it's about four
light years across,
if you go from point to point.
If you go from one
side to the other side,
this is about-- not
four light years.
Sorry.
This is 4 million light years.
Four light years is just
the distance from us
to the Alpha Centauri.
So that was nothing.
That would only take that a
Voyager 1 80,000 years to get.
This is 4 million light years.
So 4 million times the
distance to the nearest star.
But even this is-- I mean I'm
starting to stumble on my words
because there's really no words
to describe it-- even this is
small on an intergalactic scale.
Because when you zoom out more,
you can see our Local Group.
Our local group is
right over here.
And this right over here
is the Virgo Super Cluster.
And each dot here is
at least one galaxy.
But it might be more
than one galaxy.
And the diameter here is
150 million light years.
So what we saw in the Local
Group, in the last diagram,
the distance from the
Milky Way to Andromeda,
which was 2 and 1/2
million light years, which
would be just a little
dot just like that,
that would be the
distance between the Milky
Way and Andromeda.
And now, we're looking at
the Virgo Super Cluster
that is 150 million light years.
But we're not done yet.
We can zoom out even more.
We can zoom out even
more, and over here.
So you had your
Virgo Super Cluster,
150 million light years
was that last diagram,
this diagram right over here.
I want to keep both of them
on the screen if I can.
This diagram right here, 150
million light years across.
That would fit right about
here on this diagram.
So this is all of the super
clusters that are near us.
And once again, "near" has to be
used very, very, very loosely.
Here, this distance is about
150 million light years.
A billion light years
is-- two, three,
four, five-- a billion light
years is about from here
to there.
So we're starting to talk
on a fairly massive--
I guess we've always been
talking on a massive scale.
But now, it's an even
more massive scale.
But we're still not done.
Because this whole
diagram-- now these dots
that you're seeing now, I
want to make it very clear.
These aren't stars.
These aren't even
clusters of stars.
clusters of millions
or even billions of stars.
Each of these dots are
clusters of galaxies,
each of those galaxies
having hundreds of billions
to trillions of stars.
So we're just on an unbelievably
massive scale at this point.
But we're still not done.
We're still not done.
This is roughly about a
billion light years across.
But right here is
actually the best estimate
of the visible universe.
And in future
videos, we're going
to talk a lot more about what
the visible universe means.
So if you were to
zoom out enough,
this entire diagram right here,
about a billion light years,
would fit just like that.
So we're talking about a super
small amount of this part
right here.
And this is just the
visible universe.
I want to make it clear.
This is not the entire universe.
And we say it's the
visible universe
because think about
what's happening.
When we think about
the a point out here,
and we're observing
it, and that's let's
say 13 billion light years away.
Let's say that point 13 billion.
We're going to talk
more about this
in future videos, 13
billion light years.
And I feel it's
almost a sacrilege
to be writing on this because
this complexity that we're
seeing here is
just mind boggling.
But this 13 billion light
year away object, the light
is just getting to us.
This light left some point
13 billion light years ago.
So what we're actually doing
is observing that object close
to the beginning of
the actual universe.
And the reason why it's
the visible universe
is there might have been
something a little bit
further out.
Maybe it's light hasn't reached
us yet or maybe the universe
itself, and we'll
talk more about this,
it's expanding so fast that the
light will never, ever reach
us.
So it's actually a
huge question mark
on how big the
actual universe is.
And then some people might
say, well, does it even matter?
Because this by itself
is a huge distance.
And I want to make it
clear, you might say, OK,
if this light over here, if
this is coming from 13 billion
light years away, or if this
is 13 billion light years away,
then you could say, hey, so
everything that we can observe
or that we can even
observe the past of,
the radius is about 26
billion light years.
But even there, we
have to be careful
because remember the
universe is expanding.
When this light was
emitted-- and I'll
do a whole video on this
because the geometry of it
is kind of hard to visualize--
when this light was emitted,
where we are in the
Virgo Super Cluster,
inside of the Milky Way
Galaxy, where we are
was much closer to that point.
It was on the order
of-- and I want
to make sure I get this
right-- 36 million light years.
So we were super close by, I
guess, astronomical scales.
We were super close, only
36 million light years,
to this object, when
that light was released.
But that light was coming to us
and the whole time the universe
is expanding.
So we were also moving away from
it, if you just think about all
of the space, that everything is
expanding away from each other,
And only 13 billion
years later did
it finally catch up with us.
But the whole time that
that was happening,
this object has
also been moving.
This object has also
been moving away from us.
And so our best estimate of
where this object is now,
based on how space is
expanding, is on the order
a 40 or 45 billion
light years away.
We're just observing
where that light
was emitted 13
billion years ago.
And I want to be very clear.
What we are
observing, this light
is coming from something
very, very, very primitive.
That object or that area of
space where that light was
emitted from has now
condensed into way more,
I guess, mature
astronomical structures.
If you take it from the
other point of view,
people sitting where
in this point of space
now, and they've now moved
46 billion light years out,
when they observe
our region of space,
they're not going to see us.
They're not going to
see Earth as it is now.
They're going to see
the region of space
where Earth is at a
super primitive stage,
shortly after the Big Bang.
And when I use words
like "shortly,"
I use that also loosely.
We're still talking about
hundreds of thousands
or even millions of years.
So we'll talk more about
that in a future video.
But the whole
point of this video
is it's beyond mind numbing.
I would say the last
video, about the Milky
Way, that alone
was mind numbing.
But now, we're
going in a reality
where just the Milky Way
becomes something that's
almost unbelievably
insignificant when you think
about this picture right here.
And the really
mind numbing thing
is, if someone told me that
this is the entire universe,
this by itself would certainly
put things in perspective.
But it's unknown
what's beyond it.
There's some estimates
that this might be only
be 1 times 10 to the 23rd
of the entire universe.
And it might even be the
reality that the entire universe
is smaller than this.
And that's an interesting
thing to think about.
But I'll leave you there
because I think no matter
how you think about it,
it's just-- I don't know.
I actually, before
doing this video,
I stared at some of these
photos for half an hour.
This is my least productive day
just because it's just so awe
inspiring to think about what
these dots and dots of the dots
really are.